*Windows XP startup music*
*End my life*
The green screen competition has been finished ( i dont care tho )
here are the winning contestants
But before *smirks while jizzin*
But before we begin I want to announce a new competition
do what he says bitch
I want you bros to submit your best Edgar memes
Try and make them sexual, nasty and horny.
It can be anything -
just don't make any of that 'cringey' garbage
that I like, and want you to make more of please.
No offence;
pewds shuddup
I appreciate all my fans content, without any exception,
no
just no
Trigger Warning
bloody tru m8
You're probably going to be better off from not watching this video.
THAT ACTUALLY GOES FOR ALL OF MY VIDEOS
BUT REGARDLESS LET'S CHECK THIS OUT
I LOVE SHAKING MY HIPS LIKE THIS
MARZIA: WHAT?
can't stop laughing while jizzing
SIMPLE BUT EFFECTIVE
THAT MARZIA ERECTION NEEDS TO BE A MEME IN ITSELF
(KINKY NOISES AND 10/10 DANCING)
MARZIA: wut
(SILENT ORGASM)
(DOLPHIN NOISES)
IT'S SO GOOD
GIVE PAPA POODS SOME LOVE
FUCKS SAKE, WHAT IS THIS SUPPOSED TO BE ( pewds secretly jizzing )
*kinky noises*
YOU THINK YOU'RE FUNNY?
YOU THINK I WOULDN'T THINK YOU WOULD-
OH MY GOD
(JURASSIC PARK SCENE)
WHAT IS THIS
(MORE JURASSIC PARK)
OH BOY
I THINK I KNOW WHERE THIS IS GOING
(KEEMSTAR INTRO)
WHAT IS UP DRAMA ALERT NATION
I'M YOUR HOST
K-K-KILLER KEEMSTAR
*ear-raping noises* (sound warning)
DAT ASS :O
*That ass*
SNNSHHSJ (*No human words*)
IF MARZIA SAW THIS SHED DIE
(PEWDIEPIE NOISE)
DO THIS
(INSERT MEME HERE)
Bye
WHY IS IT FUN-
IT WAS SO BAD
BUT IT WAS SO GOOD
THAT'S- I DON'T KNOW
FUCKING HELL
VERY CREATIVE
I LIKE IT
I LOVED THESE BY THE WAY
ALRIGHT
I THINK IT- *chuckle*
THIS IS SO MUCH FUN!
ALRIGHT, LET'S KEEP WATCHING SOME PORN
(STAR WARS SCENE) Laser sounds and gun bang.
WHAT
OH
bai thar
WHERE I WAS PART OF THAT MOVIE
(STAR WARS EXPLOSION)
NOOOOOOOOO
OH WHAT'S THIS
OH
IT'S HARD TO GRAB IT
(DARTH VADER MAKES DRAMATIC ENTRANCE)
IT FEELS GOOD.... THOUGH
*AMAZING TWERKING SKILLS* Dart fader likes it tho
IT HURTS A LITTLE BIT
THAT'S A LITTLE TOO HARD
(BRACE YOURSELF!)
(I TOLD YOU SO)
OH MY GOD
PSHH!
(LAUGHING)
THERE GOES ANOTHER ONE (2X)
SO GOOD SO FAR
I LOVE IT
(Coldplay - Up & Up - Official Video with special gust appearance twerkin pewds.)
(CHUCKLE)
OH MAMA
OH MAMA MIA
(COLDPLAY)
(CHUCKLE)
(COLDPLAY CONTINUES)
SO GOOD
(LAUGHS)
I LOVE WHEN I'M IN SHIT I SHOULDN'T BE IN
OH MY GOD DEFINITELY NOT SONIC
THERE'S NO ONE FASTER THAN ME
THERE, OH WOW
THAT'S A PRETTY GOOD USE OF GREEN SCREEN RIGHT THERE ( best green screen the writer of this has ever seen )
OOOH
THIS IS COOL MAN
(EVERYBODY DO THE PEWDIEPIE DANCE)
THERE'S SOME FUCKING SHIT I CAN GET INTO
THIS IS HOW YOU DANCE AT THE CLUB LADIES
JUST AIR HUMPING AND NO OTHER MOVEMENT
2, 1, BOOST IGNITION... no three because badass
HERE COMES DAT BOI
Oh shit waddup!
OH IT'S SO GOOD
*constipated pewds trying to take a shit*
*so constipated*
*you can do it pewds!*
*nearly there!*
*good boi pewds*
GREAT, GUYS
y u leave pewds out tho
I'M NOW PART OF THE SPACE PROGRAM
WHAT CAN I SAY
IT'S A BIG INVESTMENT
THEY WANTED TO GO WITH A CELEBRITY
BIG NAME,
YOU KNOW
OMG JAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAACK HES BETTER THAN POODS
Hey jack! How you doing?
*the room with me inside waiting for him to jump in bed with me*
o rly?
proove it
nice ass there jack
Nothing mysterious about it? Liar.
No, the true reason cuz im in thar
follow salty.saltbox on instagram
(LAUGHING)
THAT IS TRUE
HE DOES KEEP ME IN THE CLOSET
THEN COME OUT PEWDS! come outta da closet
OH I LOVE THIS
IT FEELS HOT
OH, YOU KNOW HAT I'M GOING TO DO WITH THIS?
WHAT IS THIS
I DON'T KNOW
HONESTLY
(Child abuse)
OH
(CRASH) (CRASH)
OH WHAT IS THIS
OH MY GOD
WHAT THE HELL
FOUND IT
OH WAIT
THERE'S MORE FOR YOU BABY
BABY
HUH
FIST
(even MORE child abuse)
or could just be rape.. Idk i was homeschooled
OH MAMA MIA
(LAUGHING)
IF MARZIA SAW THIS
SHE WOULD BE PISSED
*pewds can't breathe*
dats not normel
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS
STAY OUT YA BITCH
TOP OF THE MORNING TO YOU LADDIES
THIS IS THE FOOTAGE WHERE JACK SAW ME FOR THE FIRST TIME
WHAT THE FUCK
SIMON: AND WHAT SONG ARE YA GONNA SING
UM I'M GONNA SING
FROM HIGH SCHOOL MUSICAL
SIMON: OKAY, WELL GOOD LUCK
WHAT
WHAT?
WHAT??
THEY'RE TAKING ALL THE GRUNTS THAT I DID
WTF
HEY HOW'S GOING MY NAME IS PEWDIEPIE
AND THIS IS WHAT I DO-
MADE WITH CAMTASIA FREE TRIAL
WOW
THIS FEELS LIKE IT IS FULL OF MEMES INSIDE OF IT
*a wild group of memes appear!*
I CAN'T TELL IF THIS IS IRONIC
OR THE PUREST FORM OF CAN.... sa
BAD SINGER: YOU USED TO CALL ME ON MY LANDLINE *google it*
OH MAMA
OH MAMA MIA
YEAH THAT'S THE DANCE AGAIN
DRAKE: CALL ME ON MY LANDLINE *like I said, if you haven't already, google it*
THOSE DANCE MOVES (2X)
HOW'S IT GOING BRO'S. THIS IS PEWDIEPIE.
OH WHAT IS THIS OH!
OH I LOVE THIS!
DID YOU JUST MAKE YOURSELF GET FUCKED BY ME?
WHAT THE-
DAMN YOU LIKE THAT
(Spanking sounds)
FIST!
WHAT THE HELL!!!
THAT IS SOME WEIRD SHIT MAN. THAT IS SOME WEIRD FUCKING SHIT. UMM UGH KEEP IT UP!?
THE WORLD IS BETTER
JUST BECAUSE THERE'S NO WAR DOESN'T MEAN THERE'S PEACE.
HOW'S IT GOING BRO'S
PFFT
UMMM
CALL UPON THE DARK LORDS
THIS IS A FUCKING AWESOMELY MADE MOVIE... Go see it m8
THAT WAS IMPRESSIVE MAN
THAT WAS FUCKING GOOD MAN
WHAT THE HELL
THAT'S NOT A HORSE
I DON'T HAVE A JACUZZI
WHAT
WHAT??? FUCK YOU!
YEAH! YOU BETTER!
BROFIST FROM FRANCE
THAT WAS AWESOME!
SO CREATIVE.
GOOD SHIT MAN!
YOU WANNA SEE A MAGIC TRICK?
YES
I CAN FLY
OH
PERFECT SONG
PERFECT
ear rape begins
EAR RAPE
GOOD SHIT
SUPER SMASH BRO'S SPECIAL EDITION.
WHERE AM I?
DAMMIT CHOOSE JACK
PEEEEWDIEPIE 2X
HEY YOU!
FUCK YOU!
I DON'T LIKE YOU!
PREPARE TO FIGHT
(BOWSER GROWLS)
BATTLE COMMENCES
AW HELL YA!
THAT'S RIGHT BOWSER! FUCK YOU!
THESE ARE VERY AWESOME AND CREATIVE
I'M ACTUALLY REALLY IMPRESSED.
IF MARZIA SAW THIS, SHE'D BE PISSED
WHAT AM I DOING?
nice dick tho poods
FOUND IT
OH
EVERYONE TYPE IN THE CHAT "PEWDIEPIE IS A STUPID NIGGA"
THAT WAS AWESOME
Keyboard cat coming sewn
WHAT IS UP! (5X)
OOH
POP MA PANTS
OKAY
I DIDN'T EXPECT SONGS TO COME OUT OF IT, THAT'S SO COOL.
BACK UP!!! NOW!
KEEP HIM OFF!
YOU WANNA SEE A MAGIC TRICK!!!
NAW *insert OOOOOOOOOOOHHH here*
DO YOU?
I'M LISTENING
VOTE TRUMP
GO ON, DO IT!
IT'S SO BAD BUT IT'S SO GOOD
I'M LISTENING (AGAIN)
VOTE TRUMP (AGAIN)
OH MAN
OH YEAH I WAS PART OF THE REVENANT, I COMPLETLY FORGOT ABOUT THAT
LIKE THIS?
OR LIKE THIS?
THIS IS ACTUALLY A DREAM OF MINE  WHERE ME AND HIM HAVE A ONE NIGHT STAND
VOTE TRUMP.
OH NO
WHAT?
OH MY GOD
I DON'T KNOW MAN
PLEASE SHOW YOUR FACE AROUND THE PARTS, MALCOLM, MALCOLM YOU'RE DEAD TO ME.
NOT TO WORRY
WE'VE PREPARED A SPECIAL RITUAL FOR YOU.
THAT LOOKED SO REAL
*masturbating*
OH MY GOD IT'S SO BEAUTIFUL
I'VE GONE THROUGH HALF OF THEM
I'M GONNA HALF TO SPLIT THIS ONE INTO TWO PARTS
CAUSE IT'S GONNA GO ON WAY TOO LONG
BUT
JUST HUGE
HUGE THANKS TO EVERYONE
THAT SUBMITTED
I AM SO IMPRESSED BY THIS ROUND OF GREEN SCREEN SUBMISSIONS
I LOVE THESE KINDS OF VIDEOS BECAUSE
WE ARE DOING IT TOGETHER AND
I THINK IT'S SO BAD
SO JUST STAWP
I'LL MAKE PART TWO, IN THE MEAN WHILE
Y'ALL CAN START DOING MEMES
AND SHIT
WE CUT SO MUCH
LIKE IF
IF YOU'RE JUST GOING TO SUBMIT A SHITTY ONE
MAKE IT A FUNNY SHITTY ONE
ALRIGHT
LEAVE A LIKE IF YOU ENJOYED THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR WATCHING AIDS AS ALWAYS
BROS,
YOU'RE AWESOME
IF YOU SEE THIS SAY IN THE COMMENTS JACKSEPTICEYE LOVE MARKIPLYER